key bonsoir à tous je suis très content
d'être parmi vous en fait je suis et
juju jefferies être en retard
j'habite bruxelles je prends le train
tous les jours donc
et puis bon il arrive de temps à autre
que le train soit en retard dans notre
beau pays
c'était mon cas voilà bon vous savez
comment ça se passe dans ce coin là sas
a certainement dû arriver à certains
d'entre vous on voit leur qui avance ou
alors qu'avant son ou la laisse un petit
peu courir pendant quelques secondes on
se dit non ça va j'ai le temps et puis
et puis un moment donné on réalise qu'il
faut quand même courir alors c'est dans
ces moments là qu'on se dit avec un peu
de chance le train aura aussi du retard
c'est ce que je me suis dit du coup
qu'est ce qu'on fait mais prend son
téléphone on regarde les horaires
là aussi je pense que certains d'entre
vous connaissent cette application dont
certains beaucoup même et puis et puis
et puis ben étant donné que j'avais le
nez dans mon téléphone qu'est ce que
j'ai fait j'ai failli prendre à un
pylône dans la figure
ça c'est un exemple en fait à la fois de
la bénédiction et la malédiction fin de
la chance et la malédiction que l'on a
d'avoir des applications comme par
exemple sa de la sncb dans notre poche
c'est à dire qu'on a de l'information à
disposition qui va cependant être très
monopolisant qu est ce que je vous
propose de faire aujourd'hui c'est de
parler en fait d'une d'une technologie
qu'on commence d'entendre commence de
plus en plus à entendre parler c'est à
dire la réalité augmentée et puis ma
pour commencer j'ai rejoué la scène mais
cette fois ci avec des lunettes
alors ce soir je vais les appeler des
lunettes magiques
en fait c'est des lunettes plastique
j'ai récupéré dans un cinéma donc elle
doit absolument rien de technologique
mais elles vont permettre de déguster un
petit peu la suite de mon propos donc la
gare de namur
voilà je chausse mes lunettes magiques
et à la place d'avoir en fait d'avoir en
fait l'information sur mon téléphone je
les qui s'affiche en fait sur mon chemin
voilà elle est là mon train et 8 minutes
en retard visiblement mais l'avantagé en
fait c'est que l'information se retrouve
maintenant au moment où j'en ai besoin
c'est à dire alors que je suis en train
de courir vers la gare de namur et au
bon endroit sur la gare voilà donc ça
c'est un exemple aurait été augmentés
alors j'ai utilisé pour le coût des
lunettes la chose importante en fait
c'est que les lieux c'est que les
lunettes c'est de la technologie et
finalement la technologie n'est pas ce
qui est plus intéressant où sont plutôt
c'est pas ce sur quoi on devrait se
focaliser quand on parle de technologie
on parle de réalité augmentée on parle
aussi parfois de réalité virtuelle petit
concours fais un petit exercice je suis
professeur d'université un petit
exercice pour avant de continuer si je
vous montre la photo de gauche qui pense
que c'est de la réalité virtuelle
quelques courageux qui pensent qu'il
arrêtait augmenté beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus la réalité augmentée alors là ce
qu'ils disent est vrai été augmenté
c'est juste
en fait ce que vous avez la photo de
droite c'est la réalité virtuelle
pourquoi parce qu'on prend un
utilisateur et on le projette en fait
dans un monde complètement imaginaire ça
peut être un jeu vidéo par exemple
l'occurrence je crois que c'était un
système créé dans une université pour
enfin pour créer des dessins dans de
nouveaux un espace complètement
imaginaire virtuel sur l'image de gauche
donc celle sur laquelle je vous posais
la question
là c'est une homme c'est une artiste qui
est en train de créer un personnage
virtuel mais le personnage est posé sur
sa table
alors la réalité virtuelle là comme ça
ça fait très haut science fiction dans
les faits d'abord c'est une chose très
importante c'est que là vous avez
d'abord la réalité vous avez imaginaire
complet et justement entre l'allée la
réalité virtuelle donc l'exemple que je
vous montrais finalement on peut
apporter de plus en plus de virtuel sur
la réalité
et puis bon on peut faire la même chose
de l'autre côté c'est à dire prendre
l'extrême imaginaire pourrait être un
monde virtuel dans lequel on n'aurait
aucun être humain qui est vrai qu'il
évoluerait et puis rajouter de plus en
plus en fait de réels dedans ce qui est
intéressant là c'est que vous n'avez pas
comme ça un bloc qui est virtuel un bloc
gazier à quel est le réel mais vous avez
tout une succession en fait une heure un
continuum on peut prendre de nouveau la
gare de namur rajouter un petit peu
d'informations virtuel par exemple un
horaire de train ou alors peut-être un
peu plus d'informations etc n'ont pas le
rap est donc en fait je reviens
maintenant la réalité augmentée c'est
quelque chose qui est 6,9 que ça si vous
regardez l'image en haut à gauche
donc c'est un saint cockpit d'avion dans
un cockpit d'avion vous avez en fait un
horizon artificiel c'est la ligne la
ligne horizontale que l'on voit au
milieu qui est calqué en fait qui permet
d'abord aux pilotes de savoir que
l'attitude de son avion
et puis qui est calqué bas sur l'horizon
réels c'est à dire que pour le coup
c'est effectivement une information
virtuel qui vient se calquer sur
l'information réelle
on est en plein dans la réalité dans la
réalité augmentée et ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que ça fait quand même
quelques dizaines d'années que ce genre
de système existe donc quand vous avez
des fabricants qui annoncent à tue-tête
la réalité augmentée va être le futur en
fait ça fait quelques temps qu'elle est
déjà là en outre et exemple en haut à
droite ça c'est moi qui ai pris la photo
via mon téléphone portable vous trouvez
maintenant des applications qui vous
permettent
de voir à quoi ressemblerait une
certaines pièces demeure en après pièces
d'ameublement dans votre espace pour le
coup j'ai pris le cas d'une d'une
cuisine américaine que j'ai installé en
fait dans le coin de cette pièce un jour
où une de mes collègues donner un cours
je me dis que ça serait intéressant pour
université d'ailleurs en fait
d'installer une cuisine américaine dans
le point de cette pièce pas que je m'en
parle
sinon vous avez des jeux en bas à droite
ça c'est justement ce qui fait
légèrement les gros titres ce qui est
assez intéressant c'est que finalement
pour le moment la réalité augmentée dans
le cas des jeux vidéo
y'a pas grand chose c'est ça tiendrait
sa fin certaines entreprises voudraient
utilisés comme produits d'appel mais
finalement ça ne part pas
particulièrement
et puis après vous avez les chercheurs
là c'est la dernière être l'image en bas
à gauche
c'est un projet qui a été présenté lors
d'une conférence ted bundy d'x men ted
c'est un projet qui vient du et mighty
alors ça vient du et mighty mais quand
même petite note ça a été créé par une
chercheuse belge qui s'appelle pattie
maes donc emma es dans le deuil dans le
nom
l'idée l'idée de ce projet qui
s'appelait 6 100 c'était justement de se
poser la question finalement l'intérêt
de la réalité augmentée qu'est ce que
c'est c'est d'avoir de l'information au
bon moment au bon endroit
et là les kz2 en fait ce projet 6 100
prenait tout un ensemble de cas
d'application est l'un des cas c'était
par exemple l'utilisateur qui a un
journal en papier donc le journal qui
permet de prendre un certain recul par
raport de l'information qui permet
d'avoir de l'analyse et puis par rapport
à une news cette alliance était le cas
d'exemple vous avez une vidéo qui
viennent à qui vient d'apparaître de
l'information en temps réel qui vient se
rajouter en fait sur l'analyse à plus
long terme
mélangeant du coup autant le raid que le
virtuel ça c'est quelques les exemples
est encore en illustrer 2 ou 3 1 qui est
là pour le coup autant vous avait pas
grand chose dans le jeu vidéo autant pas
contre la maintenance
dans l'industrie lourde actuellement la
réalité augmentée est en train de
prendre beaucoup d'importance pourquoi
parce qu'un technicien qui vient
travailler en fait sur un système
complexe qu'est ce qui se passe
il a généralement une forme de 600 pages
ce nom qui vont lui donner en fait la
documentation nécessaire pour pouvoir
faire la maintenance du système
si vous transformez la foire de 600
pages en une application sur une
tablette qui vient en plus rajouté de
l'information sur le système c'est tout
c'est beaucoup plus pratique
d'ailleurs petite note pour les
étudiants de l'université de namur
il ya un de vos collègues en
informatique fatalement qui est en train
de faire son mémoire sur le sujet après
au niveau médical là aussi à des jeux et
d'applications qui sont en train
d'arriver
les étudiants en médecine je sais pas si
dans votre cursus si elle le fait de
devoir un moment donné trouver une veine
alors il ya des systèmes qui existent
pour ça c'est sûr ça s'appelle des
ventures en anglais dans le texte sont
des systèmes en fait qu'ils vont
projeter une librairie lumière
infrarouge la lumière infrarouge va être
captée par par les vaisseaux sanguins
mais pas partout le enfin par toutes les
cellules qui sont autour
et derrière vous avez un système en fait
cette espèce de petite boîte blanche que
vous avez sur la gauche qui va analyser
cette image et l'art projeté en lumière
visible de manière à ce que seuls les
veines enfin que les veines ressortent
clairement par rapport au reste
évidemment c'est beaucoup plus facile
après de pouvoir appliquer dans double
en droit en dernier exemple là cette
fois ci sur la droite à sa vieille
université de munich en allemagne
là on est déjà on va un petit peu plus
loin
une radio dans alors là de nouveau les
étudiants en médecine vous êtes bien
meilleur en médecine com - très
clairement mais je peux imaginer que ça
pourrait être par exemple une une radio
d'une fracture une reconstruction en 3d
de la fracture qui est projeté
directement lors d'une opération sur le
pied du passion de manière en fait avoir
de nouveaux l'information au bon moment
au bon endroit
la formation de la fracture pendant la
chirurgie finalement pas du côté grand
public
alors y avait la cuisine américaine dont
je parlais auparavant et puis il ya
aussi la chasse aux créatures
imaginaires certains d'entre vous
connaissent peut-être
et puis finalement si je parlerais été
augmenté certains d'entre vous ont peut
se rappelle peut-être un certain projet
d'une certaines multinationales bien
connu un moteur de recherche notamment
qui est très casse et massif en fait en
termes de voix là il ya 4 5 ans vous
vous souvenez peut-être avait beaucoup
de battage médiatique en fait autour de
ces lunettes de réalité augmentée qu'ils
avaient un qui voulait en fait mettre
sur le marché la question où sont elles
qu'est ce qui s'est passé je peux vous
le dire les unes est techniquement
parlant fonctionnait bien par contre en
fait les ya eu quelque chose comme demi
de personnes qui ont eu accès comme bêta
test à ses lunettes etc en fait qu'on
considère instituteurs ont aidé les
lunettes en main qu'on a réalisé que les
applications qui était proposé c'était
dans le désordre avoir des informations
de la bourse avoir des informations sur
votre prochain vol
si vous allez dans un aéroport
lire ses emails prendre une photo et
puis là l'envoyer sur un réseau social
vous admettrez que ça fait un peu léger
et surtout si je rêve si je reprends
cette liste donc la bourse vol l'avion
email photos c'est exactement le genre
de système que vous trouvez là dessus
donc la seule distinction en fait c'est
que à la place d'avoir l'information
dans votre main vous l'aviez sur le bout
du nez
c'est pour ça que je vous disais
auparavant quand on parle de technologie
très avancée souvent le focus est mis
beaucoup sur la technologie sur le
matériel alors qu'en fait c'est les
tâches qui vont faire la différence
c'est ce que vous allez en faire
en tant qu'utilisateur pour la petite
histoire ses lunettes n'ont pas
totalement disparu
le constructeur est en fait en train de
l'est de les renvoyer vers la
maintenance industrielle justement parce
que là par contre et les besoins
bon tout ça ça fait c'est pas si mal
mais maintenant ce que je vous invite à
faire c'est d'abord retourner à la gare
de namur
et puis reprendre mon exemple auparavant
j'avais donc mon affichage qui était
apparu le train est en retard
dommage qu'est ce que je fais ah
attendez il ya deuxième information qui
vient d'apparaître ici là cette fois ci
si l'information alors ça na pas avoir
ce n'a pas directement à voir avec mon
train en retard
quoiqu un petit peu c'est la boulangerie
de la gare qui m'indique tiens on a vu
que votre train était en retard on fait
10 % de rabais sur le café croissants au
delà de cinq minutes de retard mais pour
avoir beaucoup tillon et attendez il ya
une troisième information là qui
apparaît cette fois ci plus tôt par là
là cette fois c'est une compagnie taxi m
à destination qui est en train de me
dire tiens on sait que votre est en
retard il ya de grandes chances et les
statistiques datasite serra que le train
ne refera pas son retard on peut vous
faire en sorte que vous ayez un taxi qui
vous attendent et une 4e 4 est
maintenant 4ème informations ça commence
à faire beaucoup
c'est en fait c'est le danger c'est le
danger de la réalité augmentée c'est à
dire qu'à partir du moment où vous avez
une information vous en avez une 2ème
3ème 4ème une dixième en fait vous avez
un danger de ce qu'on appelle la
surcharge informationnelle qui est ce
dont j'ai de surcharge informationnelle
je vous propose d'en découvrir une
version alors complètement imaginaire
c'est une oeuvre d'art mais c'est une
oeuvre d'art qui illustre bien en fait
ce qui peut arriver dans le cas d'une
réalité augmentée poussée à son extrême
c'est une vidéo qui s'appelle hyper
reality ça a été conçu par an par un
artiste qui s'appelle keichi matsuda est
donc ils imaginent en fait un monde où
tout son environnement fin les étapes
qui suivent simplement sa descente de
bus marcher dans la rue et serra est
couvert en fait d'informations de deux
dauphins de liens de 20 jours
honnêtement aller voir la vidéo complète
donc de nouveaux repères reality vous la
trouvez sur internet facilement
la vidéo est fascinante ça c'est la
vision cauchemardesque
c'est la vision où le réel disparaît car
m et du coup la dernière question que je
vous propose de poser c'est si je
reprends à mon âme a droit dans la
réalité et puis d'imaginaire complet ou
là beaucoup la vision cauchemardesque où
est ce qu'on trouve en fait l' équilibre
alors une bonne nouvelle pour vous
finalement à quelque part c'est nous qui
allons les secondes de double d'opposer
la limite si par exemple je prends le
cas des sites web vous retrouver sur un
site web qui est couvert de publicité
qu'est ce que vous faites
soit vous n'y retrouverez n'est plus soi
vous installez un blogueur publicité
donc finalement c'est aussi nous en tant
qu'utilisateur qui pouvons contrôler en
tout cas en partie ce danger de surface
de deux chercheurs de surcharge
informationnelle et du coup vous
en dernier mot ce que je vous encourage
ray en fait à faire c'est que d'abord
lorsque l'on parle de réalité augmentée
ne vous focalisez pas exclusivement sur
le matériel le matériel de nouveau la
technologie mais la technologie est
toujours en fait au service ce que vous
en tant qu'utilisateur allait en faire
ensuite
l'arrêté augmenté risque d'être une
bénédiction pour les publicitaires à ce
niveau là justement garder un esprit
critique
normal et sur ces mots j'espère en fait
que mon train de retour sur un peu plus
alors que celui de l'année je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]